les forêts vosgiennes et franc comtoise
summer au banc des accusés les plus
acides cette pollution a déjà causé de
nombreux dégâts dans d'autres pays
industralisés comme l'allemagne
mais c'est en grèce et en italie que des
mesures énergiques ont été prises pour
limiter les dégâts avec notamment les
pots catalytiques
mais surtout l'interdiction d'utiliser
une voiture particulière un week-end sur
deux pour la première fois en franche
comté et dans les vosges
cette mesure sera appliquée dès le
week-end prochain c'est la plaque
minéralogique de votre véhicule qui
servira de repère une semaine ce seront
les numéros pairs qui pourront partir en
week-end
la semaine suivante les numéros impairs
un ensemble de mesures qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité chez les usagers
[Musique]
pas du tout
ce qu'on a
c'est trop a cependant mal pourquoi vos
trucs c'est normal faut s'habituer
ces produits uniquement à limiter la
pollution est ce que vous pensez qu'il
nous en suisse vous vous êtes suisse et
se seraient déjà en suisse
non pas encore mais on a une situation
il ya dix ans était interdite le
dimanche de rouler ses habitués aussi à
cette situation la faute peut-être à
faire une fois les sectes pourquoi pas
total matière de la chose
non pas du tout
complètement inadmissible ça me dérange
pas remarqué j'ai pas de perdre la
semaine prochaine
j'en ai eu une la semaine d'après donc
avec un peu de chance si ça tombe bien
ça devrait aller enfin ça ne me dérange
pas
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal pour
limiter la pollution ah ben non non je
celui qui veut rouler le auquel mon jeu
je trouve ça tout à fait normal qu'ils
roulent le week-end voilà
coop et ma mère
vous rappelez du montage photo
surtout quand on est dans le droit taupe
et l'assurance que la vignette on paye
déjà les sens assez cher
franchement
françois michaud l'italie en grèce pour
écouter venez pas me raconter des
conneries s'il vous plaît mais moi je
suis en france je travaille je suis ici
depuis cinq ans je m'excuse je suis venu
ici bosser je n'ai amené pas du tout ce
genre d'histoire parce que on a déjà
fait les sales italie en italie certains
marchés je vois pas pourquoi dans un
pays comme la france un pays qui
souhaite qui sait kiev soit disant
civilisés par camille zèle et régionales
je ne paie pas de mettre ce genre
d'histoire je n'ai pas mettre notre
région servira donc de test national
n'oubliez pas ce week-end les voitures
avec un numéro impair ne devront pas
roulé la police a déjà reçu des
directives
[Musique]